Speaker 1: For months now, we've been hearing
from Republicans about the Biden bribery scandal.
Now, if you're wondering, David, what on earth
are you talking about?
What Biden bribery scandal.
That is the right reaction because it is a
Biden bribery scandal with very little bribery,
no evidence and a whistleblower no one's been
able to speak to for three years.
We'll get to that in a moment.
But the new development here is that our friend,
Democratic Congressman Jamie Raskin, has now
released the transcript of the Ukrainian oligarch
who supposedly was involved in the bribery,
saying, I've never even spoken to Joe Biden.
This is yet it.
If you're paying attention, this wouldn't
be a surprise.
But if you were one of the people who has
been only loosely hearing about Biden bribery
and may be thinking any second now, the other
shoe is going to drop and we're going to find
out about Joe Biden's crimes.
Then you are going to be quite surprised by
this, Jamie.
This is HuffPost.
Jamie Raskin releases Transcript of Ukrainian
oligarch denying he talked to Joe Biden.
They did the bribery, but they never spoke.
Burisma co-founder Mykola Liszewski, who Republicans
claim bribed Biden, says in the transcript,
no one from his company ever had any contacts
with Vice President Biden.
That is extraordinarily clear.
As the article explains, Republicans claim
there is evidence a Burisma executive apparently
still, Chayefsky paid Joe Biden a $5 million
bribe when he was vice president in exchange
for unofficial favor.
They've demanded the FBI hand over a document
reflecting a confidential source.
This conversation with Jeff Ski.
Raskin has now countered with a document of
his own.
A three page transcript of a 2019 interview
between Slush Chayefsky and an acquaintance
of Rudy Giuliani, who at the time was publicly
slick, seeking dirt on Biden on behalf of
then-President Donald Trump.
This is a quote from Slush Chayefsky in the
transcript.
Quote, No one from Burisma ever had any contacts
with Vice President Biden or people working
for him.
During Hunter Biden's engagement, when asked
if Vice President Biden had assisted him or
his company in any way slush, Chayefsky says
no.
So Chayefsky says no.
In full disclosure, this next paragraph is
relevant and then we'll move on to further
analysis.
In 2015, a Burisma executive named Vadym Pozharskyi
thanked Hunter Biden in an email for having
the chance to meet Joe Biden at a charity
dinner.
Other guests told The New York Times they
don't recall Joe Biden having any substantive
conversation with Bashar.
It was a handshake by all of the evidence
that we have.
So think about the multiple layers here.
Now, if I came to some of these conspiracy
theorists and said, okay.
The guy from Burisma says he never met Biden.
They could say, well, the bribes happened
through intermediaries.
Even if you didn't meet Biden, people working
for you could have met with people working
for Joe Biden.
Okay.
Hypothetically, that's possible.
Number one, we have no evidence of that.
And more importantly, number two, the claim
here from the Chayefsky in the transcript
is very clear.
No one at Burisma.
Not just Liszewski.
No one at Burisma has had contact with anyone
working for Joe Biden.
So this rules out it precludes the possibility
of this.
It was intermediaries.
Now, I think it is important to remember that
every aspect of this story has fallen apart.
It's also important to remember that if Jamie
Raskin had access to this transcript, Republicans
also did, because this was a transcript related
to I believe it was the impeachment of Trump,
one of the impeachments of Trump.
So not only have Republicans like James Colmer
and others been insisting that this is a thing
absent evidence, Republicans, if we understand
this correctly, had access to the this exact
same transcript dating all the way back to
at least a few years, and yet they continued
to make claims like this claim.
I'm sorry.
They continue to make claims that they have
evidence of bribery.
But when they were questioned about it, they
said things like the following.
Here is James Colmer admitting, We don't even
know if these supposed tapes that we have
proving Biden bribery are legitimate.
Speaker 2: When will you be able to confirm
if these recordings are legit never going
to take?
Speaker 3: Well, I can confirm that the recordings
were in the 1023.
Remember, I was with Senator Grassley when
we saw the unredacted version.
So because Grassley was saying alleged yesterday.
Speaker 2: So these recordings are legit,
you can confirm they are legitimate.
Speaker 3: Well, they were I can confirm they
were listed in the 1023 that they were redacted.
I don't know if they're legit or not, but
we know that the foreign national claims he
has them.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So this was like one of the first of a thousand
signals that this may not really be what some
of these Republicans are claiming that it
is.
We have alleged tapes from a purported whistleblower
claiming, okay, we're like three layers removed
already and we actually have very, very little.
Here is James Colmer being interviewed by
Sean HANNITY.
This is not new material.
This is just kind of painting the picture
for you about why we shouldn't be surprised
that this is evaporating before our very eyes.
Like when you pour water on cotton candy and
it just becomes nothing.
Here is James Colmer saying, Well, yeah, the
whistleblower with the tapes.
We also kind of like haven't spoken to the
whistleblower in three years with.
Speaker 3: Respect to the tapes.
Look, it mentioned in the form that the oligarch
had 17 tapes, Biden two with Joe Biden, except
in the broad that he used that as in answering
this oligarch is a high ranking, was a high
ranking member or owner of Burisma.
Yes, that is exactly right.
So have you had any conversation with him?
Unfortunately, nobody's had any contact with
him for the last three years, you know?
Yeah, MSNBC makes fun of me when I said that
there are a lot of people that were involved
in the Biden shenanigans that that are currently
missing.
But with respect to these.
Speaker 1: Guys, why will you not jail Biden
on the basis of alleged tapes we don't have.
From a whistleblower no one's found for three
years.
Isn't that enough to imprison Biden for life?
So, again, if you've been following this show
for a while, we have not been ignoring the
Biden bribery story.
We've been covering the Biden bribery story
for what it is, which is a series of unfounded
allegations with evidence they don't have
from whistleblowers they can't reach.
And now the latest is, Hey, we have a transcript
from 2019 where the guy who supposedly is
going to blow the blow the roof off of this
thing actually says, I haven't spoken to Biden,
my staff hasn't spoken to Biden, my staff
hasn't spoken to any of Biden's staff.
There is just nothing here.
Joe Biden committed a crime, investigate,
prosecute, jail him.
If that's what the law says, I'm not going
to stand in the way.
But right now it is all like wet cotton candy,
leaving crumbs evaporating before
our
very eyes.